judiciaire jean charles marchiani 60 ans
est un personnage sulfureux homme de
l'ombre et du secret il affirme avoir
toujours agi dans l'intérêt de la france
dans le sillage de charles pasqua
il a notamment obtenu la libération des
otages français au liban en 1988 mais
son nom est également associé à
plusieurs affaires de commissions
occultes pour lesquels la justice le
poursuit aujourd'hui ahmed tazir jean
charles marchiani aux côtés de charles
pasqua
un couple indissociable en politique
comme devant la justice alors que le
second n'est pour l'instant pas
inquiéter jean charles marchiani lui a
passé toute la journée dans le bureau du
juge courroye mise en cause dans cinq
dossiers le magistrat ne le poursuit
pour l'instant que dans une seule
affaire la vente d'armes présumées
illégales vers l'angola
nous sommes dans les années 90 le pays
est alors ravagé par la guerre civile
face aux rebelles de l'unita le pouvoir
ne peut plus opposer grand chose et
s'adresse un homme d'affaires français
pierre falcone
objectif obtenir des armes les contrats
se succèdent kalachnikov munitions
grenades entre 93 et 95
il y en a pour plus de 500 millions de
dollars falcone aurait récompensé ses
appuis
le ministère de l'intérieur français son
intermédiaire
l'ex préfet marchiani aurait reçu 750
mille dollars de commissions occultes
octobre 95 mme arkani reprend du service
lors de la prise d'otages de deux
pilotes français en bosnie le juge
courroye veut savoir pourquoi marchiani
à décorer cet homme arcadi gaydamak
le milliardaire russe a permis la
libération des otages selon le juge
courroye l'ordre national du mérite
aurait été monnayée via un versement à
une association proche de charles pasqua
un spécialiste dans la libération
d'otages les réseaux marchiani
permettent le dénouement dans la sphère
des otages du liban quatre jours avant
la présidentielle de 88
aujourd'hui comme hier lors de sa
première mise en examen en 2001 jean
charles marchiani a toujours reçu le
soutien de son mentor l'ex ministre de
l'intérieur charles pasqua et marchiani
est elle est restée sa peau pour sortir
les otages du liban
qu'est ce qu'on trouve à dire
aujourd'hui le sordide affaire at-il en
rien à voir avec la réalité
eh ben je suis je suis écoeuré sur l'été
à l'angleterre
il aurait été fait chevalier s'il avait
été aux états unis lors été couverte
nous on est des minables agents secrets
commerçants préfet ou politique
selon les juges l'homme l'a visiblement
pas su choisir
longtemps protégé par son immunité
parlementaire
l'ex député européen n'est plus
intouchable il vient d'être mise en
examen le juge courroye a demandé son
placement en détention provisoire
un juge des libertés doit statuer sur le
mandat de dépôt dans la soirée charles
pasqua lui n'a reçu aucune convocation
pour l'instant